welcome to this video playing Maria blah
my astro ASX I have this guy before what
is this name I likes a QV f okay let's
do something funny here I want some
funny pollution he's not he's not really
complying what what kind of nonsense is
that I mean the only good thing about
this is that is not so easy to break
down I think I had to had this before
actually against this guy but isn't this
just good now for me I mean cakes i have
bishop f2 and here 94 I mean he simply
does not develop takes Bishop fts kingi
to yeah this is just just about holding
and what now we are putting putting
pressure on on the g3 porn I guess rook
da door something he obviously cannot
castle
yeah rook da does let's look simple
simple but but strong King eat ooh I
play rook h 20 gauge to us was already
winning actually now I cannot play that
but I can take d 3 and 4 a winning
position and let's think about it here
for a moment is there something better
than just going to the endgame his king
is not in good shape but yeah it should
still be be very good let's let's just
play this a technical fashion 27 and
stuff c6 night is a problem it must be
improved I dearly and may be traded on
d6 okays retreating to be three probably
hmm I don't know
yeah okay I can still just go to the six
the night is not especially great on b3
as well but it's not so great 96 but it
is good yeah i mean ii for is a big
weakness so why not okay King here why
it is not exactly in a position to do
much yeah I don't know maybe trade one
look it's not not that essential I think
it's really just mostly this this extra
pawn that will kill him so I'm going to
do that it's not the most maybe not so
logical i want to take and a techie form
long-term with this bishop I don't know
what I'm doing with it we have tons of
pawns on dark square so I'm going to
just trade this keep it keep it simple
way to play F ifs are another long-term
thing to go for night will come here so
i will we regroup at to d6 ok so a
five-year f5 it it's not so nice to
trade off his weakness but there is a
new weakness on g3 so I don't mind that
so much
okay so please I don't know where what
is exactly what he's doing here exactly
I can regroup to f6 or i can do you can
also play rook here I mean I'm not I'm
not exactly in a hurry let me think
about it if I try to go to f6 see my
play Knight f3 to g5 that's that's not
so great i'm not sure if I ever want to
take on your form well some rook
endgames might be promising how do I do
this the most convincing way and not
totally sure about it Emeli and check
with the pawn that's not that's not top
leading to that much I probably have to
do that get the night to have six it's
not not bad anyway why he might attack
f5 then yeah this is this is not not so
easy yeah it takes a five then time when
he I it's okay time morning yes that's
it surprisingly tricky from a technical
Porsche here it really is I have to go
back am NOT not what I wanted to do I
mean not nothing terrible happened it's
just just not easy to to make progress
at some point I have to take you
check check check check so two points
now but as long as there are nights on
the boat it's a it's tricky night h7 I
have to avoid rookie 6 wait if you take
your first check come on check
the H pawn should be quite dangerous I
thought g-force winning now but maybe
it's not all right it is it is check the
problem is I only have one second check
which makes it a bit difficult I cannot
do this in this time even that night
against the Queen in like five seconds
it's not possible at least not for me
this is I mean I don't know what would
really very weird game but um I'm very
very weird game I don't know it was it
also it was somewhat surprisingly
difficult maybe I should maybe hear a
five or something I should play a five
somehow I mean I never spoiled it i just
i just lost lost lots of time in a way
and Joe I think this is this is
basically okay it is really okay but
check nah man I'm running here all along
it just have no I have no time on the
okay well thanks for watching